I think there'd be a probably bigger audience for that than there is for our C++ content here. Speaking of which... What? What C++ content? The closest we've had to C++ content is the Python script that you're currently running. Welcome to ADSP, the podcast, episode 66, recorded on February 5th, 2022. My name is Connor, and today with my co-host Bryce, we quickly solve a wordle in record time and then hop into some exciting C++ news. Also, find out which co-host guest got COVID. All right, you ready you ready here we go folks so this is this is the wordle for february 5th 2022 so so do we want to try do we want to try irate instead of a rose i don't really know i
want to do a rose we're playing or we're we are traditionalists here we are traditionalists in the hardcore wordle school you ready yeah oh we might get it in two we might get it in two i already have a decent guess but let's see if we can come up with the same guess individually actually i've got two guesses now well let's see i want want probably – hang on. Let me think. I probably – So actually, we're not even – Jesus, we're terrible podcast hosts. Oh, yeah. We have not explained what happened. So we guessed a rose, and we got the A and the O, the first letter and the third letter, both green, both in the correct position. So it's going to be A blank, O blank blank.
I mean, I think I want like an A-L-O word. One of my words is like that. Yeah. Then what would the rest be? A-L-O. You definitely know one of them. Do I? Yeah.
The next letter is an N. Oh, no. I was thinking alone, but that doesn't work. An N? Yeah. What goes after an N? I doesn't work. An in? Yeah, what goes after an in? I don't know. What is it? Along. Oh, along, yeah.
However, let's not guess that yet because I have another guess that is avoid. I feel like that's riskier. It is riskier, but the question is, we're going for this in two. We've got solid info here. My guess is that the list of words is less than 10. We've got a really good shot of getting it here. Well, we should think of... And the thing is, although avoid is lower, like axiom, except the I would be the third letter so i guess the appeal of void is we get um
i is higher frequency than l and is a vowel and we get i get yeah i guess that's really you get i and then agony agony is another word so here's the thing was we should just take a couple minutes to come up with words that fit this pattern And then choose the one that overlap the most So agony and along Both share an N and a G Which makes Abbott Is that a word?
A-B-O-T-T I'm not actually sure if that's an That's a bad That's a terrible guess though Because it's got two Ts I think Abbott is what would be good I feel like A-X-O. What about ATO words?
Like a tone? No, no, no E, but... Epoxy? I think that's a word. Although my guess is that's not a valid word or word. But that also, that's the thing is I'm guessing there's a few that end in Y. No, I think epoxy's got to be a valid one. Yeah, like anganine.
But what about the ATOs? Is there any ATO? A loft? That has a T and an L. I like that one. What about, are there any A question mark OU question mark words? Allowed? Yeah, good one.
Yeah, yeah, allowed. That's a good one. About? About, yeah, allowed. That's a good one. About. About, yeah. I don't know how to say it as a Canadian, but... So I think we actually have a decent number of guesses here. So what's the most common letters? L shows up.
I, L, T. We only got I in one of these, but we have L, T in a bunch. Oh, no, we only have L, T in loft. Well, L shows up three times t shows up twice um so i think it has to be one of the l words yeah yeah um i feel like a loud i mean a loud is probably better than a loft because the f if is i think unlikely or the f doesn't appear in any others whereas for a loud it does appear in other words. You know what? Here's another reason why allowed is nice is because I guess the D might be in place.
Oh, right, right. Yeah. Yeah, let's do allowed. I like it. Yeah, let's do allowed. Okay. All right. Oh!
Brutal! No. So, aloft? So let the listener know. It could be aloft or it could be along. Let the listener know, though. Oh, sorry. We did aloud.
We got the L in place. So we know it's a word that starts with A-L-O. Between aloft and along, I would guess, you know, it's going to be so sad if it was a long, like my first, my first guess was actually the two, but a loft is less likely to be a word-a-word in my opinion. A long is definitely a word-a-word. Should we do it? Yeah, I say we just go with a long. Okay, please, please don't do this to us, a word-a-dle. Oh, God. Oh, no. So we, once again, we tried along and we missed on the N and the G. We need to think about whether there's any other words
that are not, like, aloft because it's going to be embarrassing. Nah, I say we just go for it. You want to just go for it? It's got a T in it. We still got two guesses after this. Jesus. Yeah.
I mean, I mean, still pretty decent. Still also interesting to know that if you skip a day, you lose your streak. No, no, that's not true because I haven't done it. I have not done it two days in a row and it said I had a streak. And that may be it. But didn't we, that one said our current streak on the computer is only one. Yeah, you're right. You're right.
So very interesting. Brutal. Brutal. Honestly, what can you do though in that situation? We nailed it. All three words. I mean a lot. Well, we could have not played the hardcore strategy.
Maybe we would have gotten there in three. No, but that's the thing is like we. If we were guessing for more letters for the second guess, what would we have guessed? Wait, let me fill in first. So our third guess was along, and then our fourth guess was aloft. So just in case it wasn't clear, we got it on aloft. Oh, yes, yes. We did get it on aloft.
And so here's the thing. We came up with, what was it, eight, nine words. The word that it was was on that list. So good job to us. And I think our strategy was solid. If it was a void, we would have locked it in for sure. And so we would have got it in three. I think the order we...
How would we have gotten it in three? So if it was a void and we guessed aloud as our second one, the only word that ended in D on our list other than aloud was a void. But that was what you pointed out. You were like, oh, if we go with aloud, we're locking it in if it ends up being a void. And then the L narrowed it down to only two other words on our list. What I want to know is how many of the words that it could have been did we get? Oh, yeah, yeah.
So here's my – and you know what I'll do? Connor wrote a little program for this, of course. In Python, I'll note. did we get oh yeah yeah so here we here's my um and i you know what i'll do i'll kind of write a little program for this of course in python i'll note he wrote it in python not in c++ this is true i would have written it in python too i would have written it in python or bash you probably would have written it in bash did you use did you use rapids did you use numpy and coonumeric no i did I did not. Alright, then we run it. Interesting, interesting. So here, I'll share a screenshot with you.
Are there a lot more words than we thought? There was 30 words using the Scrabble dictionary. Only using Wordle words, there was 12. Where do you get the Wordle word set from? You can just find it on if you Google Wordle word list,
it takes you to a Reddit, which then redirects you to a GitHub text file. Do you embed it in the script? Oh, it's just, yeah. It's just, no, it's not. It's just a text file in my folder. And by the way, for people who are worried about the New York Times takeover of Wordle, you can just download Wordle plus the JavaScript file. The website is just like, it's all client side.
It's just the web, one HTML page plus like one JavaScript file. So you can just download it and then like play Wordle forever because the word list, everything is just in that JavaScript file. So even after the New York Times takes the reins of Wordle. So there's 12 12 12 word valid words the first script the words that are in red does that is that the ones that aren't wordle words yeah a hold isn't a wordle word come on so oh we didn't get adopt i guess adopt is one that we should have i would have actually maybe the full the full list of 12 valid wordle words after a rose that go A blank O are
Aloud, we got that. Along, we got that. Aloft, we got that. Afoul, we missed. About, we got. Among, we missed. Adopt, we missed. Agony, we got.
Avoid, we got. A toll, we did not get. A foot, we missed as well. And aloof, we also missed. And actually based on the fact that after allowed, the three valid guesses left were along, aloft, and aloof. We actually should have guessed aloft because it would have told us that it was aloof if we missed. So actually the only reason that my program puts it as the last guess is that it has a duplicate o it always ranks duplicates last yeah that's interesting yeah well we did okay we did okay
i think we still did it was a song and also to irate tiktoks yeah i don't i don't think you know what's up i don't think you know what's up okay okay? Okay? Wordle TikTok, you have been challenged. Yeah, listen to your ADSP fathers here, you little TikTokers. Maybe we need to start a new podcast that's just about Wordle. I mean, I think there'd be a probably bigger audience for that than there is for our C++ content here. Speaking of which. What? What?
What C++ content here. Speaking of which... What? What C++ content? The closest we've had to C++ content is the Python script that you're currently running. No, no. So here we go. We're going to wrap up. I might release that all as just one episode because I don't think we can do two back-to-back Wordle episodes. Our listeners are going to get pissed. So now we're going to actually record. But if Wordle's a fad and the fad fades and then you
release the second Wordle episode after, you know. It's definitely getting released, but just not are we really going to do two back-to-back episode? I feel like you have to. I feel like you have to. Because, like, Connor, it's become such a big part of our life and our relationship.
And then there was the Wordle phase of ADSP. What tea are you drinking? It is imported merchies from Vancouver, British Columbia, all the way imported to Toronto. And it is Miss Grey. I was going to judge you for your tea, but I've actually had tea in Vancouver. I've had very good tea experiences in Vancouver. On Victoria, well, on Victoria Island specifically.
Vancouver Island is the name of the island. And Victoria is the name of the city that's on Vancouver Island. But we'll forgive you. You're American. You're American. You're New Yorker. You're from the East Coast. We're at what? Episode 67, 68? episode 67 68 take for us to miss a friday um pandemic didn't do it oh yeah should we should we talk about
tail end uh tail end of this oh my god yeah we should like we didn't even talk about that that's good yeah so unfortunately um yeah i I got COVID. I like how you were going to start into like, unfortunately, I don't get it. I'm just like, I don't got COVID. Also, too, remember that I made a list of the two things we were supposed to talk about? We haven't talked about either of those. I have a thing that we have to talk about, too. But let's why don't you talk about your COVID experience? Yeah, well, very briefly, I got it. I had both vaccinations, but my booster got canceled on January 17th because of a snowstorm. Thanks, Canada.
And it was pretty rough. I got to say, get your boosters, get your shots, and stay healthy because it sucked. Can you still, like, you're okay though now? Oh, yeah, yeah. Thanks to Bryce who didn't send me medical. So Connor tells me he thinks he may have COVID on, like, last Thursday. And I'm like, Connor, like, okay, like, can you get a test? I think you said you can't go out to get the rapid test because if you're feeling symptoms, then like they tell you to not go get the test. And like, I guess you can't get them at the pharmacies up there.
It's ridiculous. So like without spending 30 minutes talking about this, you cannot currently. At one point, they were giving them out slash selling them rapid test. Now at the current state of affairs, February 5th, 2022. And this has been the case for the past couple of weeks when I got it. You can't go buy them rapid test now at the current state of affairs february 5th 2022 and this has been the case for the past couple weeks when i got it you can't go buy a rapid test you can go get one administered for 40 canadian but you have to be asymptomatic at most locations some locations so like you're allowed to go get a rapid test if you don't think you have covid basically yeah there are a few locations that do take symptomatic
individuals and yeah, it's 40 bucks everywhere. And I don't, and I, and you have to qualify for a PCR test, which if you've tested positive, you do not qualify. Like you have to be pregnant. You have to be indigenous or a couple other things. And so like I tested positive on a rapid test and was like, okay, can I get a PCR test test and they're like sorry you don't qualify so so but but the way the way that connor got or the way so so connor tells me like he basically doesn't have access to tests and i'm like connor like send me your address and he sends me his address and i just like immediately stop what i'm doing and i go and i get two of the rapid tests and i live in midtown manhattan so i walk 10 minutes i go into a fedex and i'm like i need this to be in canada tomorrow
and the fedex people were like were very helpful one of them uh i hope i'm not getting anybody in trouble but i feel like it'd be hard to track this down one of them is like but i might be admitting to an international crime here one of them is like um like filling out the form and then another person comes in they're like whoa no no put down that it's personal effects because apparently if you put down that it's rapid tests then like the canadian border guards hold up the package for some period of time. And so I overnight FedExed this to Connor at exorbitant costs. And like they were like, well, there's two options for like overnighting it. And like one of them is like cost $4 more and gets there like at 9 a.m. to 1 p.m.
And the other one is like $4 cheaper and gets there like at 9 a.m to 1 p.m and the other one is like four dollars cheaper and gets there in like the afternoon and like the the the the cost for this shipment was like four dollars was very small relative to how much this is going to cost i'm like sure i'll pay the extra four dollars for it to get there in like the morning and i'm like all excited i tweet connor and connor's like wow i can't believe you shipped it already and so then like the next morning comes and the package goes from like having like a very firm like delivery date to showing up as like pending and they're like operational delay and i'm like what the heck and then they didn't show up for like another day or two so now i'm like
oh no not another day or two it was supposed to show up on Friday didn't show up till Monday oh my god I like I want my money back FedEx if you're listening I want my money back like thank you for helping me smuggle these rapid tests into Canada but I expected you to smuggle them into Canada next day Connor needed me and because of you, I let him down. But anyways, you were able to get a test and now are you now COVID testing negative? Well, so that's the thing is I have to take one later today. So I initially tested on a Tuesday. Do you need me to send you more? No, I still have three of them left. So I initially tested negative on a Tuesday because someone who I'd spent a lot of time with tested positive. And I was like, well, I should, if they've got COVID, I should have gotten COVID. And I tested
negative. And I also felt totally fine. So I was like, okay. Then like Wednesday felt a tickle in the back of my throat. Thursday was definitely sick. And that's when I was like, well, most of these places, I can't go get a rapid test. You FedExed, didn't show up on Friday. So I went and got another rapid test, tested positive. And then I took one of Bryce's rapid tests this past Tuesday, which is we're recording this on a Saturday right now, and still tested positive, even though my quarantining period was done.
And supposedly Omicron, it's supposed to disappear from the test results. stay tuned listener i'm doing fine but um take your shots get your boosters i went and got my booster on wednesday aren't you supposed to not get the booster when like when you have covid uh so no like the quarantine period was supposed to be you you know, five days now and you're, you're supposed to still get it. And then Canada came out and issued on Friday, two days after I got the booster announcement saying, if you've just been infected, don't get it for eight weeks. But that, that recommendation didn't come out two days until after, after I got the
booster. So, you know, constantly changing. But I think I'm, like, super inoculated at the moment. Yeah. And to wrap up this episode. Wait, wait, wait. In lighter news, Eric Niebler's keyboard has been found. I don't think we technically get to take credit, but we're going to take credit.
Oh, yeah. We're going to. Oh, we're definitely taking credit. Like, the keyboard was missing we announced on the third most popular c++ podcast soon to be second soon to be second we're coming for you cpp chat we announced that his keyboard was missing and then magically somebody some good and wonderful and excellent person who I desperately hope listens to this podcast found the keyboard and sent it back to Apple and Apple sent it to Eric. And now Eric has his keyboard.
Do you mean Facebook or do you mean Apple? Facebook. Facebook is what I meant. Speaking of Apple. Yes. I'm probably thinking of Apple because. You can say it because this won't come up for like a month. My dear colleague, Olivier, who's been at NVIDIA for 20 years or 19.7 years.
I'm going to round up on his behalf. If it was me that was leaving NVIDIA after being here for 19.7 years, you know me. I would just say I've been here for 20 years. But Olivier left NVIDIA this week and is going to Apple, where he will be the director of GPU compute at Apple. So I'm very excited for him. And so that's probably why I have Apple on the mind. Yeah. Congratulations, Olivier.
It'll be sad to see you go. We'll still see you at conferences. We're going to have you on this podcast at some point, and then it won't be three guys who work at NVIDIA. It'll be two guys who work at NVIDIA and one guy who works at Apple. Yeah. So before Olivier left, literally in his last hour or two of being an NVIDIA employee, I'd been badgering him for the past week or two,
like, send me all your slides. Make sure that I have all your slide decks and so then he sent me like three emails with like all of his slide decks and so now like i have like an email folder that's just like olivier slide weaponry and it's like i feel like i've been given like the crown jewels yeah it's like i have this great responsibility to use these slides. Because Olivier was amazing at taking information and turning it into very effective weaponized slides that could just convince anybody of anything. Yep. And so now I have inherited those slides. Yep. Eric Kneebler, Facebook and the keyboard,
Olivier and Apple. And we also have one other piece of news. Future guest. Who? Started at NVIDIA. Oh my God. Yes. Andre will be on this podcast
at some point in the near future because Andre Alicandrescu now works at NVIDIA. Has that been like, is that common knowledge yet yeah yeah it's on linkedin there's a twitter thread that talks about it yeah we can talk about that yeah andre so we now have andre eric um oh like if you if y'all think i am done hiring c++ people let me tell you i have plansVIDIA has the best C++ team out there. And if you want to come and be a part of that team, you come contact me. You let me know. You let me know. I'm hiring. Yep. Pretty exciting. Maybe we'll even have to... Actually, we'll let the listener wait. The listener's now listening to this sometime in March, and we're recording this at the beginning
of February, which means that whenever we do record with Andre, it's going to be like, it's going to be like April or May by the time it's out. So I was going to say, Oh, we should maybe get them on and then just like cut them in. We'll cut them in. We'll let them jump the line, but no, we'll let the listener wait. You gotta, you gotta, you know, that's what happens when you are the soon to be number two C++ podcast. The contents, it's just so juicy, but you got to wait for it. I think we got an exciting year ahead of us because, you know, like guest-wise we're going to have Andre, we're going to have Tony Van Erd. I think we should have.
We still got to have back Dave Abrahams. Yeah, we got to have Kate Gregory on for sure. Yeah. We're going to branch out. We're going to get some Rust folks. We're going to maybe bring on a Go folks. A Go folk. A Gopher.
Go 1.18 came out. They got generics now. It's big news. Big news. That was the big problem with the Go. We're going to have Chandler back sometime this summer. Are we? Yeah.
You don't know why yet, but you'll see. You'll see. It's going to be cool. Holy smokes. we yeah you don't know why yet but but you'll see you'll see it's gonna be it's gonna be cool holy smokes even even even some juicy stuff that i don't know about that uh bryce is keeping from me well you know it's you know chandler's got the best stories he's got the best stories does he have the best stories like after sean he probably has the best i mean sean almost killed a couple people but like sean's just such a next level. Not wait. Let me roll that back.
Let me roll that back. Near misses on people's deaths does not necessarily make a great story. Please do not go out and nearly kill people to get on ADSP. That's not. We do. We do not endorse. We are not legally near death experiences to get on this podcast but that said it better be good it better be really good
like we we we take no responsibility but um like if you have a great story about a time that you smuggled something across the canadian border let us know yeah i'm gonna i'm gonna get arrested when i come to cpp north the little the little horse police are gonna be waiting for me at the border this is the beautiful thing is that we don't really take this podcast too seriously. Like our other podcast, this is a random tangent because this landing of this episode
is real rough. I wanted the executive producer, Bob Terrio, to cut in a clip of the Internet is Evil song from the Bo Burnham special or whatever, or Internet is Evil song from the Bo Burnham special or whatever, or Internet is Everywhere.
Ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha. Could I interest you in everything all of the time? A bit of everything, all of the time Apathy's a tragedy and boredom is a crime Anything and everything, all of the time Could I interest you in everything, all of the time A little bit of everything, all of the time Apathy's a tragedy and boredom is a crime
Anything and everything, and Anything and everything and anything and everything and anything and everything and all of the time. And he was worried about, like, copyright. And I was like, my guy, nobody listens to our, like, in the scheme of podcasts, nobody's like, the podcast
police are not listening to a Raycast and ADSP. Don't worry, if we do get sued, my mother's a lawyer and she'll, she'll represent us. Right, mom? We, that's awesome. We actually have an ADSP. We've got, we've got a legal team. Yeah. Yeah. So, so really like. Bryce's mom's our legal team. What's up? What's good? Come at us lawyers. I don't know if any of you know my mother, but you know me and you know that I'm pretty, pretty, I'm a handful. So like before you, before you think about suing us, think about whether you want to deal with the lawyer version of me. Um, like,
yeah, cause that's a little, a little much. Yeah. That's awesome. We've got a legal, we've got a legal team here at ADSP, the podcast. It's Bryce's mom. And that's like, it sounds like, you know. And if you're like a big company, Connor's dad is going to go find like whatever stuff you did. Connor used to tell me these stories about how like he'd meet, like people would be like, the companies would be like terrified of his dad. So don't mess with this podcast. Yeah, that's true. My dad's a journalist that when
certain when he shows up like red flags get raised in corporate whatever and emails get sent is oh oh shoot gourd hookstra is uh he's on the phone this isn't good this isn't good so unless you want that so so so stay away from us unless you want that to happen to you. Yeah. But seriously, please don't sue us. Well, so what are the clips? We've got the Fiddler on the Roof tradition. Did you listen to that one? I guess I have to now.
It's the best, man. I cut in a whole like 60 seconds of Fiddler on the Roof. I think that's domain now i think we're good there yeah but we're well okay but where'd you get the clip from uh i mean i'm not i'm not gonna give the people that want to sue us material if you want to sue us you're gonna have to do your work okay and we're gonna counter sue you real fast because we've got a legal team here at ADSP, the podcast. And, you know, what do you think you and your mom do all that yoga for? It's to be nimble and quick. Boom.
Countersuit. Slander. All right. Jeff, I hope that answers your question. Thank you for putting up with us, Jeff. uh we love you we love all of our listeners tune in next time to find out who jeff is and hear our answer to his question thanks for listening we hope you enjoyed and have a great day There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.